if skankfest if you could describe it as
one drug what would it be oh interesting
I think it would be some weird research
chemical that uh you can only get off
like a 53-year-old dude who lives down
at the end of the Cold attack or like a
15-year-old on the dark web it's
something that doesn't have a name it
just has like a molecule and like a
binary code cuz it's really hard to
describe like I mean it's it's euphoric
it's also very daunting it sends you on
this like wild erratic Thrill Ride cuz
every time I'm on stage I want
to prove that I'm funny cuz there's so
much expectation for me to be funny
after last year it's good and then when
you get off stage there just this like
violent Comedown dude so yeah I
really don't think that there's a drug
out there yet besides like maybe
adrenochrome you know I think this was
like the feeling of this place was
harvested from a terrified 8-year-old
boy